♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR THE ONLY ESPIONAGE THREAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT IS RUSSIA
EVEN THOUGH THE WORST THING
ANYONE HAS PINNED ON
VLADIMIR PUTIN SO FAR IS A
HANDFUL OF DOPEY FACEBOOK ADS
THAT ALMOST NOBODY SAW BUT JUST
BECAUSE THE RUSSIAN THREAT IS
GROTESQUELY OVERBLOWN DOESN'T
MEAN THAT FOREIGN SPYING IS IN A
PROBLEM FOR US.
IT DEFINITELY IS A PROBLEM.
CHINESE SPYING IS THE REAL
PROBLEM.
CHINA IS OUR MAIN RIVAL ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT SPIES ON
US RELENTLESSLY.
ON OUR COMPANIES, OUR MILITARY,
OUR GOVERNMENT.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF CHINESE
NATIONALS WHO LIVE IN THE
UNITED STATES, MOST OF THEM ARE
HARMLESS, BUT SOME LARGE NUMBER
OF THEM ARE SPIES.
IN MARCH OF 2016 A CHINESE
NATIONAL PLEADED GUILTY TO
HELPING HACK THE COMPUTER
NETWORKS OF MAJOR DEFENSE
CONTRACTORS.
DATA RELATED TO THE CFIUS
STRATEGIC TRANSPORT AIRCRAFT IN
THE F35 FIGHTER JET WAS STOLEN
AND MADE ITS WAY BACK TO CHINA.
IF THAT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME THE
CHINESE HAVE STOLEN VITAL
MILITARY SECRETS.
THEIR INDUSTRIAL ESPIONAGE IS IF
ANYTHING EVEN MORE AGGRESSIVE.
EARLIER THIS YEAR CHINESE WIND
TURBINE COMPANY WAS CONVICTED OF
PAYING AN ENGINEER TO STEAL
SECRETS FROM AN AMERICAN
MANUFACTURER.
TO ADD INSULT TO INJURY, AFTER
STEALING THE INFORMATION, THE
CHINESE COMPANY THEN CANCELED
$800 MILLION IN CONTRACTS.
THIS IS NOT UNCOMMON.
IF THE U.S. TRADE REPRESENTATIVE
ESTIMATES THE OVERALL COST FROM
CHINA STAFFED AN AMERICAN
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY,
INDUSTRIAL SECRETS, COULD REACH
$600 BILLION EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
THAT'S ALMOST AS MUCH AS ALL
ANNUAL TRADE BETWEEN THIS
COUNTRY AND CHINA.
CHINESE BUSINESSES ARE
THEMSELVES A FRONT FOR MORE
CONVENTIONAL ESPIONAGE SINCE
MAJOR CHINESE COMPANIES ARE BY
DEFINITION CLOSELY INTERTWINED
WITH THE COMMUNIST PARTY AND THE
CHINESE MILITARY IN MANY CASES.
INTELLIGENCE EXPERTS WARNED THAT
THE CHINESE MOBILE COMPANIES DTE
COULD EASILY BEGIN SPYING ON ANY
AMERICAN WHO OWNS THEIR PRODUCTS
WHERE THEY ALLOWED TO EXPAND
THEIR SHARE OF THE U.S.
MARKET, AS THEY ARE CURRENTLY
TRYING TO DO.
THOSE ARE JUST CELL PHONES.
HOW ABOUT EMAIL, AND OTHER
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS?
ACCORDING TO A HIGH LEVEL
GOVERNMENT SCORES ATOMIC SOURCE
WHO SPOKE TO US IN THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT ARTIE HAS DIRECT OR
INDIRECT CONTROL MUCH OF THE
ARCHITECTURE OF OUR INTERNET IN
THIS COUNTRY.
IF CHINA WANTS TO KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE DOING THEY PROBABLY ARTIE
CAN.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN EXACTLY?
HOW DID WE GET TO THIS PLACE?
SLOWLY AND INTENTIONALLY ON THE
PART OF CHINA.
OUR LEADERS MEANWHILE WERE NOT
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE CHINESE
THREAT.
SOME OF THEM KNEW ABOUT IT BUT
DIDN'T CARE.
IF THEY ARE GETTING VERY RICH
FROM CHINA.
NOT COINCIDENTALLY SOME OF THESE
VERY SAME PEOPLE ARE THE ONES
NOW TELLING YOU THAT RUSSIA IS
THE BIGGEST THREAT WE FACE.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT THEY
ARE LYING AND THEY KNOW THEY ARE
LYING ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE REALLY
DOING IS TRYING TO COVER THEIR
TRACKS.
LONGER THAN ALMOST ANY OTHER
AMERICAN JOURNALIST.
A SENIOR EDITOR AT
"THE WASHINGTON FREE BEACON" AND
THE OFFER OF I WAR, WAR AND
PEACE IN THE INFORMATION AGE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON >> GOOD TO
BE HERE.
>> Tucker: GIVE US A SENSE IF
YOU CAN, I KNOW IT'S A COMPLEX
TOPIC, BUT GIVE US THE SENSE OF
THE SCALE OF CHINESE SPYING ON
AMERICAN INDUSTRIES.
>> IT'S A THREE-PRONGED THREAT.
YOU HAVE TRADITIONAL SPYING.
RIGHT NOW IN ALEXANDRIA THERE
ARE TWO EX-CIA OFFICERS WHO ARE
UNDER INVESTIGATION OR BEING
PROSECUTED FOR SPYING RELATED
ACTIVITIES IN CHINA.
THEN YOU HAVE THE CYBER THREAT,
AND THIS IS A MASSIVE THEFT OF
TECHNOLOGY FROM BOTH THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND LAST ARE WHAT THEY
CALL THE NONTRADITIONAL
COLLECTORS, THAT'S THE 350,000
CHINESE STUDENTS HERE,
RESEARCHERS, ACADEMICS AND THEY
ARE ALL WORKING TOGETHER AS MUCH
A SECRET GOVERNMENT -- CHINESE
GOVERNMENT DIRECTED PROGRAM,
THEY ARE GOING AFTER THE CUTTING
EDGE STUFF RIGHT NOW.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
QUANTUM COMPUTING.
>> Tucker: SO WHO IS MINDING
THE STORE?
WHO WAS PROTECTING AMERICAN
INDUSTRIAL SECRETS AND MILITARY
DATA?
>> IT'S THE FBI'S JOB TO GO
AFTER CHINESE SPIES.
JUST THIS WEEK THE HEAD OF THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE UNIT CALLED
THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE CENTER SAID
THAT NOT ENOUGH HAS BEEN DONE TO
DEAL WITH THIS CHINESE ESPIONAGE
AND TECHNOLOGY COLLECTION
THREAT.
HE BASICALLY UPGRADED THE
DURING THE OBAMA PERIOD WHERE
THEY DIDN'T GO AFTER THIS AT
ALL, NOW HE SAYS IT'S A GRAVE
THREAT TO U.S. NATIONAL SECURITY
AND IT'S PRIMARILY IN THIS
ECONOMIC SPHERE THAT THEY ARE
GOING AFTER OUR SECRETS AS WELL
AS MILITARY TECHNOLOGY AS WELL.
>> Tucker: GIVEN THAT THE
CHINESE ECONOMY IS ABOUT TO
SURPASS AMERICA'S INSIDES
ASSUMING IT HASN'T ALREADY, THEY
ARE OBVIOUSLY OUR MAIN RIVAL IN
THE WORLD STAGE, WHY DIDN'T THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION FOR EIGHT
YEARS RESPOND TO WHAT IS CLEARLY
THE PREEMINENT THREAT WE FACE?
>> IT'S THE SAME THING WITH THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
THEY KNEW ABOUT THE RUSSIA
INTERFERENCE GOING BACK TO 2015
AND DID NOTHING.
BASICALLY IT'S BEEN A PASSIVE
APPROACH.
THEY RELY ON JUST DIPLOMATIC
NICETIES AND THEY BASICALLY
IGNORED THIS GROWING
INTELLIGENCE THREAT THAT AS YOU
SAID, THE MASSIVE AMOUNTS HAVE
BEEN TOTALED BETWEEN
200,000,000,600,000,000,000
ANNUALLY IN OUR MOST CUTTING
EDGE TECHNOLOGIES.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD THINK
THAT AMERICAN INDUSTRY FROM HOME
THIS DATA IS BEING STOLEN WOULD
BE COMPLAINING IN PUBLIC, BUT
THEY ARE NOT.
>> THEY ARE NOT.
THERE WAS A MEETING LAST YEAR
WITH A LOT OF THE TECH CHIEFS
WITH TRUMP IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND BASICALLY ALL OF THEM SAID
YOU'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING TO
CUT OFF THIS CHINESE THEFT OF
TECHNOLOGY.
THEY ARE JUST PILLAGING
EVERYTHING THAT SILICON VALLEY
HAS AND THERE HAS BEEN LITERALLY
NOTHING DONE TO TRY AND STOP
THAT.
>> Tucker: ABSOLUTELY
TERRIFYING.
VERY QUICKLY, DO YOU THINK I'M
ALMOST A RHETORICAL QUESTION,
BUT THE RELENTLESS FOCUS ON
RUSSIA HACKING OUR ELECTION
WHATEVER THAT MEANS, DOES NOT
DETRACT FROM OUR AWARENESS IN
OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND TO CHINA?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
RUSSIA DOES POSE A THREAT BUT
IT'S A DIFFERENT LEVEL OF A
THREAT.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
THE TWO ECONOMIES.
THE RUSSIAN ECONOMY IS SEVEN
TIMES SMALLER THAN THE CHINESE
ECONOMY, SO THEY ARE NOT AS
GREAT A THREAT AS CHINA, SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT TAKE
ACTION TO STOP THE CHINESE